[Música]
exitoso despegue con el telescopio
espacial europeo conocido como euclí del
telescopio se dirige a un viaje que lo
llevará a 1,5 millones de kilómetros del
planeta tierra su misión desvelar
algunos de los secretos mejor guardados
del universo
esencialmente no sabemos De qué está
hecho el universo no sabemos Cuáles son
los componentes fundamentales de este
universo en su estado actual es una
verdadera vergüenza francamente que
desconozcamos más del 90% del universo
sabemos mucho más sobre la materia
oscura que sobre la energía oscura Pero
el hecho de que no sepamos Realmente si
se trata de energía oscura o de que no
entendamos la relatividad general y la
gravedad a grandes escalas es una
cuestión fundamental
el observatorio clip valorado en 1400
millones de euros despegó en un cohete
falcon 9 fabricado por spacex de elon
musk se encargará de car tografiar miles
de millones de galaxias En búsqueda de
excesos de energía y materia es único
tiene un sistema óptico fenomenal para
obtener imágenes realmente nítidas de
las Galaxias ya hará un estudio del
orden de un billón y medio de galaxias
en todo nuestro universo en el espacio
tridimensional Así que no solo la
posición sino también la distancia
el mapa tridimensional del Cosmos que
elaborará el telescopio abarcará tanto
el espacio como el tiempo para tratar de
explicar cómo evolucionó el universo
oscuro y por qué se está acelerando su
expansión esta misión durará al menos
seis años